Thank you so much for coming.
I know how busy you all are with work
and errands and snarking about me on
your cell phone.
Let it go, Claire. Honestly, Phil, I
don't know how you do it.
I don't know how you do it. Compromise
and compassion.
She wasn't really asking you.
Here comes Luke. What do we say we were
doing today?
When has Luke ever showed any interest
in what we do?
Okay, but be cool. If he finds out you
were tracking his phone, he'll think we
don't trust him.
Plus, then I can never do it again.
Hey, guys.
What's up? How was your day?
It was fine. You know, we don't know.
How would we.
Know? We've just mean.
What did you
do? Not like. What did you do?
We're just like, Hey, what'd you do?
You guys are acting weird.
No, we're not. You are.
What'd you do today?
We just stayed home shopping.
Online shopping at home for pants.
We both need a pants. I told you he was
going to ask.
Wait a minute. Was that your drone
today? Were you spying on us?
I'm sorry. Your mom made me do it.
She thought you were smoking grass.
Grass?No one says--
Grass. It's not that crazy an idea.
We weren't smoking anything.
Manny,
would never.
Thank you, Mom.
So, judgey about those things.
The only reason why I walked that stupid
dog is so that I can smoke my cigars in
peace.
I can't believe you're spying on us.
You have to stop being so suspicious,
Claire. It's okay to trust people.
Some people.
Other people. Who knows?
You turn your back for one second and
they have a whole nother family on the
bad side of town.
You are my other family from the bad
side of town. Look, I can't stand this
all night. I loaned someone money.
Gloria, I didn't consult you.
I knew you'd be pissed. She's just a
friend.
She?
Is this the woman that you've been
dreaming about at night?
That you've been making the sexy noises
and saying. Baby, baby, the
hell are you talking about?
No. Prove it.
Give me the
phone.
Honestly, you people.
And by that, I mean straight people are
ridiculous. Everyone's entitled to a
little bit of privacy.
Says the guy who forced me to tell him
our friend's secret? Okay, that's
different. That was gossip.
And gossip belongs to everyone.
Just keep your nose out of other
people's phones.
Either trust them or you.
Don't.
Give me that. Give me that.
Back. Give it, Mitchell.
No.
Have mine, because I have nothing to
hide.
I'll take that. Oh, my God.
Mom, no. Please stop.
Here, here. Wait. Let me help you.
You know.
It's crazy, right?
Oh no, I knew it.
Lol. Do you think Brett likes his
coffee black or with half and half?
Okay, I admit it. I have a problem.
But I only told one person it was too
juicy and Crispin said he wouldn't tell
anyone.
This is from Longinus.
Oh, that lying crisp.
And give me that.
I can not believe he betrayed my trust.
Now Peppers chiming in.
Jackals.
All of them. Oh, that pepper.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Uncle Mitchell was helping you get
me a birthday present.
Yeah.
I wanted to make you dinner and get you
a nice bottle of wine.
The one he served at New Year's.
You said you liked.
Oh, I did like that wine.
I'm sorry I ruined the surprise.
You should be. What did you think I was
doing anyways? Give me some credit.
Oh.
Oh, Well, maybe we could just call it
even since he typed, I'm just surprised
she remembered coming to my house that
night. To which you responded.
Bah ha ha ha ha ha ha.
With, like, five exclamation points.
Seems fair.
Did you find what you were looking for?
No. She's a waitress at the club.
Her boyfriend crashed her car, so I
helped her because we have that fun
game where I order salad and she brings
me French fries. But I never dreamt of
her. Last night I had a nightmare.
Joe got out onto a ledge of a tall
building. I couldn't get to him.
I was very upset, and I think I might
have cried a little in my sleep.
Which might have sounded like sex to
you. Which I don't love.
But that's the baby I was talking
about.
Really? That's scary.
Yes.
Why in God's name would I need to dream
about another woman?
Now that you say it out loud, it does
seem kind of crazy.
I'm not proud of this.
But the dream wasn't about Joe.
It was about this little baby right
here. That's right.
You almost fell off a ledge, and Daddy
was so scared.
Yeah.
I've gotten all right.
Oh, my gosh.
It's us.
All over the place.
I don't know how I feel about this.
Okay. Okay. Now, look how much you
gossip. Haley managed to capture it on
film.
And look at you smiling ear to ear.
You know, you love it when I give you
the dirt. Oh, which reminds me, guess
who got kicked out of a hotel bar for
making unwanted advances at the
waitstaff?
I don't want to know. It's none of my
business. Okay.
Jotham. Daniel. Sal, just tell me.
I don't know.
Good God. Look at those lines on my
face. When did I get so old?
There's my lines.
Because you're holding your son who you
love, who you had to protect in your
dream.
She is a great photographer.
Even though it's embarrassing that
everyone's staring at my six pack.
She is.
Really good.
Have you seen my photo?
Is Gloria seeing this?
Gloria? See what? I think I look good.
Wow. You didn't even see me in there.